Here's the thing,
calling, connection, contribution, and
control all matter, but they may not all
matter to you.
So you've got small kids right now.
Yeah, you may be like, you know what, screw
it. I'm not going to do work that
it doesn't matter if I'm getting the coffee
for the guy who gets the coffee for
the guy who gets the coffee.
My work, I don't have to have any
connection at all at work.
As long as I have control.
Yeah. Right. And as long as I can
have the contribution and be home with my
kids every night for dinner, that's all that
matters to me now.
Well, we are taught in the like consumer
industrial complex that we are just one
diet, one purchase, one promotion, one
marriage, one divorce, whatever away from
finally being happy, right?
Like I will finally I will be happy
when and the truth is
it's not it's just more stuff, right?
It's this hedonistic treadmill where you
just keep running and you keep grabbing and
you keep going for the next ring.
And what happens is you'll see these people
who are super successful.
So they they they get the promotion and
they get the money and then they join
the country club, right?
But then they're at the country club and
they notice the country club across the
street, right? That's a little nicer.
So maybe I'll work a little harder.
And then they join the one across the
street and they work a little harder and
then they're like, "Oh, well maybe then I'll
get to this thing and that thing and
that thing." And at the end of the
day, the only time they see the fancy
country club is when their kids post photos
from the pool from Instagram because they're
so busy working so they can avoid the
thing that they don't actually get to enjoy.
Right? So we're so busy trying to fulfill
everybody else's definition of what success
will finally mean.
And it's when we're so busy working towards
somebody else's definition that we lose
ourselves. And when we lose ourselves, we
don't bring our best selves to work or
to home.
Okay. So here's the job as an executive
recruiter. It is your job to call the
most successful people in the world, right?
are hired by your client to find the
most successful person and to recruit them
away from that amazing job
to work for your client.
Now, you're calling a super successful
person about a job they didn't know was
available, maybe in a company they didn't
know existed or didn't know what new
direction or exciting strategic plan they
were following. Certainly, a recruiter they
never knew existed.
So, you're starting from a pretty, you know,
you're starting pretty far behind the start
line. So, you're calling them because
they're super successful.
But despite all that success,
they aren't very happy and they're all
calling you back.
And I was fascinated.
I mean, like fascinated by the idea that
these super successful people, like on
paper, that's why I'm calling them, weren't
actually happy because you would think the
job would be really hard, right?
Call these people who like they don't know
who I am.
They're happy where they are.
They're not.
And because I thought about what makes a
good job good, these eight motivating
factors, but not what makes a good job
good for them.
Yeah.
they left and I couldn't keep them.
And so throughout these 20 years of
executive search, I just became so
fascinated by the fact that every single one
of us actually has a very different
definition of success
than each other.
But also at every age and at every
life stage, that definition also changes.
I think it starts by asking yourself whose
goal is this?
Great. Yeah. Whose goal is this?
And the reason that I did not do
well in law school is it turned out
that it was my fourth grade teacher's goal.
It was my parents goal.
It wasn't my goal.
I didn't really I walked in the very
first day and I looked around and I
was like I've made a huge mistake.
Like I don't belong here.
I don't want to be here.
This is like what is happening?
And by the way, I got horrible grades
because when you're not in a place that's
right for you, you don't bring the best
of you. And so we get very trapped
in everybody else's ideas and we don't stop
and ask ourselves.
First of all, because when we're 17,
somebody asks us to define who we should
be and we don't have the capacity to
do it. And then we also don't give
ourselves the grace to change.
We don't give ourselves the grace to say,
you know, this isn't for me.
This isn't where I want to be.
And so we we do get trapped in
this idea, this sort of external
view of what should be.
Now I love what you say in the
book you say you want we want success
to feel meaningful.
We want our work to matter.
And I I wrote this down myself here.
Everyone, including me, has a scorecard that
defines success.
Um, and for me, I think when early
in my career, it was the titles.
You know, you go into these because I
worked in an American firm.
It was like associate, VP, you know, it
was senior associate VP,
you were like a tread.
It was like, yes.
Um, but I loved how you talk about
these Four Horsemen of success.
which I I thought you were going
to talk about when you were talking about
those eight things you do as a recruiter,
but they're they're different and I just can
we just touch on those a second because
I heard you talk about them on a
few podcasts. Yes.
Why have you brought this into our our
space? This Four Horsemen of success.
Yeah. I brought them into the space because
they drive me batty.
They just drive me batty.
Okay. So, we talked about happiness, right?
Like I'll be happy when like we're okay.
It's the Four Horsemen.
Passion, purpose, happiness, and balance.
Okay, everyone is like, "Oh, I'm just
looking for more balance.
I just I'll be happy when.
Oh, follow your passion." Right?
It's just you just need purpose.
Like, it's just nonsense.
Nonsense.
The book was originally going to be called
Consonance, doing work that matters.
And a friend of mine was like, I
cannot in good conscience let you name a
book a word that nobody knows because
nobody's going to buy a book.
They don't know what the word is on
the front cover.
But if you think about it, dissonance is
like cacophony and noise and it's like organ
rejection like I have to get out of
here. I don't know where I'm going, but
I have to get out of here.
So consonance is really the opposite.
It's alignment. It's flow.
It's I love it.
I even wrote down because I kept seeing
it in in the book and it was
I was like god I really have to
go deep on this now and it's this
feeling of harmony and alignment that comes
from knowing that the very best of what
you can do is demanded to solve a
problem about which you can you care deeply
and you are being rewarded for solving
that problem in a way that is personally
financially emotionally
meaningful to you.
Yes. And it says in short, it's when
you what you do matches who you are.
That's it. Isn't that what we all want?
We want to we want to be asked
to bring the very best of everything that
we can do to something that matters to
us. We want to be rewarded in a
way that actually is interesting to us.
And so for some people it's money, for
some people it's titles, for some people
it's praise. For some people, right, it's it
could be anything.
It could be solving the problem.
But all of us define each of those
factors differently.
Let's chat about these.
The you talk about the four psychological
pillars that you go through in the
book. Calling, connection, contribution, and
control. Now, I really liked these.
so calling, we'll start with calling, a
sense of purpose or identity in the work.
Yes. Yes. So calling is it's a leader
who inspires you.
It's a mission that you want to fulfill.
It's like you with the Clinton.
Yes. It's a it is what you were
doing. I didn't care what I was doing.
It's a societal
problem that you want to solve.
It's a business you want to build.
It's a bottom line you want to grow.
It could be a family you want to
nurture. It's just that gravitational force
that gets you out of bed every single
day. I love that.
And then you've got connection, which is
understanding the relevance and impact of
the work. Basically, if you call in sick
tomorrow, will anybody care?
Will anybody notice?
If you look at your email box, if
you look at your calendar, if you look
at your to-do list, do those things get
you closer to that calling that you just
realized you had, or do they get you
farther from it?
Does your work actually matter?
Do you actually matter?
I love that.
Yeah, because I'm sure Yeah, you've made me
think about that.
If in my corporate career, if I had
been out for a day, would someone have
like gone, oh, the relevance of him not
being here today?
And actually, it's true.
You know, you do you do want someone
to say the next day, you know what,
we had that meeting yesterday, we really
missed your energy.
or your your kind of take on it.
Yes. Love that.
And you've got contribution.
How work enhances one's life goals and
stability. Okay. So, connection is all about
the work. Contribution is really all about
you. Right? So, this isn't how are you
contributing. This is how is the work
contributing to you?
Is it paying you the money to have
the life that you want?
Is it giving you the flexibility to have
the lifestyle you need?
Um, is it allowing you to have
the career trajectory that you're looking
for? Does it allow you to manifest your
values on a daily basis?
It could be any of those things or
all of those things, but does the work
give you what you need?
Does it contribute to the life that you're
trying to build?
I love it.
And the final one, control, agency over
time, decisions, and work environment.
Yes. So control is fascinating because there
are studies that show that people will take
jobs that give them more control over jobs
that give them more power.
Why? Because the amount of autonomy that we
have is actually relevant to how well we
do at work.
Like do you have control over the the
teams that you're assigned to, the metrics
that you're judged by, the how much
your hustle pays you, right?
Like how much control do you have over
just everything that affects you, the
decisions that are being made about you in
your work itself?
I love these four guys.
Calling, connection, contribution, control.
Super helpful and really great.
Even if you're going for a new job,
I think, you know, to me, the perfect
time to be thinking about it.
Well, yeah, because if you're going for a
new job,
you know, to me, these are great things
to do a bit of a gap analysis
on versus the job, right?
Does this align with my calling, connection,
contribution, control, and really using
them, you know, because with a lot of
our listeners, you know, particularly this
time of year, they're starting to think
about what's next.
And what's lovely about this limitless
assessment is that when you take the
assessment you get this radar graph at the
end which basically shows how much
connection calling contribution control you
have and then how much you want.
So if you don't want any calling, you
don't have any calling.
Awesome. You're in consonance.
If you want tons of calling, you have
none. You're not.
But my definition will be different than
yours and your definition will be different
than yours even.
happened over time.
And so when managers are thinking that their
people are just thinking about mission and
purpose and you know prestige and and you
know all of those eight motivating factors,
they're missing the boat.